this has been the most shocked I've been
with an apple system in a long long time
hey guys it's max for max tech today I'm
answering the biggest question that a
lot of you guys asked and that I'm
curious about myself
does the bring a new 2019 iMac with the
i-9 processor eight core 16 threats up
to five gigahertz does this thing over
heat or thermal throttle a lot of the
previous imax thermal draw DeLand those
are four core processors not eight cores
like this one so Apple made a big jump
but the actual design hasn't changed at
all and we still have a one single fan
inside of this machine and the first
thing I did is open TG Pro and I saw
that the fan speed is actually the same
2700 rpm maximum as we had with a 2017
model and I maxed it out when the fan
sounds exactly the same so it hasn't
changed
that's weird cuz the 2015 version
actually was a little bit faster let's
start out with Geekbench 4 I'm gonna run
the test here and what I'm looking for
is what's the maximum that the CPU is
running at so here we saw four point
seven eight I believe was the max and
what I really want to see is how close
to that 5 gigahertz can we get now intel
has been playing a lot of tricks lately
with the previous 2017 it was rated from
4.2 bass up to 4.5 not that big of a
difference and this one's going from 3.6
upto 5.0 and their advertising max
performance numbers if you're only using
one core and if your computer is running
really cool that's hard with an iMac so
far I've seen a maximum of looks like
maybe 4.8 we haven't hit 5 gigahertz yet
but we're close and I'm happy because
with the MacBook Pro that had the i9
that didn't even happen that went up to
I think four point eight or four point
nine gigahertz and what I personally
want to see and what I'm hoping for is
that we don't have the same situation
with the I&I Macs as we did with the
MacBook Pros where I returned my eye 9
MacBook Pro because there is really no
performance gain compared to even the
base processor because of that huge
amount of thermal throttling so now I
have Cinebench r15 open this is gonna
max out the CPU it's gonna allow the
fans to kick up the system's gonna heat
up and we're gonna see what kind of
performance we can get and if it starts
dipping down if you know the system gets
too hot let's go ahead and run the CPU
test here and I'm gonna keep an eye on
the max four point seven zero wow that's
higher than I expected so the maximum
clock speed under
full load is 4.7 that's pretty good
sometimes that's quite lower than the
max advertised speed but now we're
dipping down to 3.8 okay temperatures at
70 the fans aren't even moving yet
usually Apple has a slow fan curve and
we're heating up but not that fast
surprisingly the MacBook Pro is just
shot straight up on the temperature
gauge as soon as you started running the
test 1678 that's the first run there for
the CPU that's good getting close to
double what the previous one to three
point eight eight three point eight zero
so it's not running close to the maximum
speed that it could but it is above the
base clock now the 2015 iMac would that
had higher faster fanta fan speeds that
actually ran 200 megahertz under the
base clock the 2017 one ran right at the
base clock so far I'm not hearing the
fans at all that's interesting I wonder
what would happen if I just manually
enable the fans if it's not gonna go
below 3.6 and he's just not really
thermal throttling it's still running
above or at least the advertised base
speed this is really really weird
because this iMac is basically silent I
only heard the fans starting to kick up
a little bit on the fifth run and then
after about 10-15 seconds it's the
quieted down where I can hear the fans
at all whereas the 2017 after I think on
the second run it starts just to kick up
all the way so the I nine MacBook Pro
does not thermal throttle but we're also
not reaching the maximum potential it's
not staying at 4.7 gigahertz and running
all course away which would mean it
would probably heat up a lot more and
the fans would kick up that much more
but I don't know why this is happening
if we look at the power usage as soon as
we hit run it'll spike up to 120 watts
and then after a little bit it'll dip
down to about 80 or so maybe 85 and then
that will allow the heat to stay down
and that will force the frequencies to
run about 3.8 gigahertz now this could
be because maybe the power supply can't
handle having that much wattage for long
terms or maybe
is something that Apple decided to do
maybe they decided hey let's allow the
full force of the CPU of Mac's clock
speeds just to run for a short burst say
you're opening up a new application
you're doing effect and final cut or
something like that but on a longer term
let's drop down the wattage of the CPU
where the CPU is the most efficient that
way we have a lot less fan noise we have
a lot less heat and it's just gonna give
a better experience overall while still
giving us a really great performance
with that I 9 at this point I've ran
this test about 15 times and I don't
know of another Mac that's ran this
quiet including the iMac Pro which is a
very quite device but after this many
runs if the fans will start to kind of
kick up we're running this test here I'm
looking at my temperature gauge
we're idle 1196 rpm while this test is
running so here we go I've ran this test
a lot of times I'm hearing the fans kick
up they're reaching 1939 1969 it's about
halfway where previous Mac's up there
couple runs would be maxing out I don't
know if this is some new fan technology
that they have or what's going on I'm
getting very consistent results as far
as benchmarks I'm getting fans that
aren't even going up past halfway I'm
getting close to double the CPU score of
our spec tout 2017 iMac I am very very
surprised I think we're gonna leave it
at that we have a lot more testing to do
with the system we're gonna run some
different benchmarks get some numbers do
some video editing comparisons maybe
some photo editing stuff as well but
this has been the most shocked I've been
with an apple system in a long long time
so thank you guys for watching if you
guys want to see some more videos on
this iMac compared to other ones click
that little circle above we actually
have a couple suggested videos as well
we have links to imax in the video
description there's been a max and I'll
see you in the next video
[Music]